hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt bei
mir gibt's heute leckere pizza und zwar
mache ich heute eine pizza rucola und
eine pizza mit spinat und schafskäse und
index.hu cola ist ja noch ein käse rand
mit drin
ich mache heute jetzt den hefeteig den
habe ich euch ja bereits in meinem pc
grundrezept video gezeigt was ich euch
auch hier unten in der infobox
verlinkten werte und heute zeige ich
euch eine tomatensoße die ich immer ganz
gerne mache wenn der belag zum beispiel
vegetarisch isst oder einfach nicht so
wird sich ist in meinem anderen pizza
video hatte ich ja so eine stelle
tomatensoße die mache ich immer ganz
gern wenn ich zum beispiel youtube
benutzer oder salami oder die tomaten zu
heute ist eben sehr würzig ich werde
zuerst mal den hefeteig herstellen und
danach wenn die tomatensoße
der hefeteig ist jetzt gut da klebt
jetzt nicht mehr
und daraus mache ich jetzt vier pizzen
deswegen portion er jetzt im teig direkt
am anfang also einmal halbieren dann
nochmal beide hinten hatten und die form
ich jetzt zu kugeln immer von außen nach
innen so bekommt man nämlich eine glatte
kugel hier
und dann mit beiden händen rund formen
und die teige lasse ich jetzt im
separaten schüsseln auch aufgehen
das erleichtert mir später einfach das
arbeiten und in der zwischenzeit kann
ich gleich schon mal die soße einstellen
während die hefeteig dahinten jetzt noch
aufgehen werde jetzt schon mal die
tomatensoße ansetzen ich brauche viel
olivenöl eine knoblauchzehe und eine
zwiebel 2 el tomatenmark 400 gramm
tomaten aus der dose etwas oregano und
süßes paprikapulver einen halben
teelöffel zucker und eine tennis- und
etwas werde ich zuerst einmal die
zwiebel und knoblauch fein hacken
wie zwei esslöffel olivenöl in einen
kleinen topf und da kommen die
zwiebelwürfel und knoblauch würfel mit
dazu und werden da 23 minuten glasig
gedünstet
jetzt kommt das tomatenmark mit rein und
wird auch ganz kurz angebraten
und dann lösche ich die zwiebeln mit
tomaten aus der dose ab die solle der
auf jeden fall nehmen denn sie sind
einfach aromatischer als frische tomaten
comdirect zucker und salz mit rein und
auch die restlichen gewürze und da lasse
ich die soße für etwa 15 bis 20 minuten
bei leichter hitze köcheln und die zeit
mit sich dann immer ganz gerne um den
pizzabelag vorzubereiten
die hier beteiligt sind jetzt
aufgegangen
und ich werde es zuerst eine spinat hab
ich dazu bereiten an zutaten brauche ich
400 gramm spinat der weiß tiefgefroren
und den habe ich auftauen lassen
200 g schafskäse und ein paar top ten
formaten
beim spinat ist es so gerade wenn er
tief gefroren ist also ich kaufe gern
tief gefroren aber ihr müsst ihr dann
auftauen lassen und das wasser
ausdrücken und meistens ist wirklich
mehr wasser als spinnert in der
verpackung drin
naja aber er braucht 400 gramm
ausgedrückten auf getraut mit spinat
nämlich etwas mehl und stark von die
zepp drauf
da kommt da jetzt etwas mehl darüber
jetzt vorm die erstmal den rand
jetzt könnte die pizza einfach so mit
den fans
kommt etwas in meine handfläche und
damit bestreichen ich jetzt die backform
das von dem ich immer ganz gern meine
pizza backbleche die haben löcher drin
also ein paar fragt mich und dadurch
wird die pizza dann gleich richtig schön
knusprig
so jetzt kommt es da die tomatensoße
drauf
dann kommt da das spiel naht drauf
jetzt kommt da noch der krise mit drauf
und auch die pizza legt hier einfach so
viel belag wie ihr gerne möchte
und zuletzt kommen jetzt noch die
tomaten mit drauf die können die
entweder ganz drauf legen oder einfach
halbieren oder vierteln
die pizza wird dann im vorgeheizten
backofen bei 200 30 grad ober unterhitze
etwa 15 bis 20 minuten gebacken ist auf
jeden fall die unterseite kontrollieren
wenn die schön knusprig ist dann ist sie
tot und ich werde in der zwischenzeit
weiter warum
dafür brauche ich einen käse dafür geht
es in gouda ich nämlich so einen
türkischen kapitän ihre sage ich gleich
noch was dazu ich brauch mozzarella hier
noch versuche oder und später noch etwas
balsamico creme für die kraft pizza
brauche ich jetzt keinen rams den in den
rand kommt ja der käserei deswegen
streitet jetzt den teig ganz flach aus
muss ein bisschen größer als gefasst
jetzt lege ich den tag über das
backblech strüber und las wie gesagt den
rand so ein bisschen über stehen bereit
kurz den zweiten tag vor
jetzt nehme ich den käse das setzt wie
gesagt der kassen fließe und zwar
verläuft einmal ziemlich gut wir nehmen
den noch zum beispiel ganz gerne wenn
wir uns trost machen in sandwich toaster
und jetzt schneide ich den in etwa so
für stifter die sollen seit von halben
zentimeter dick sein
jetzt lege ich diese käse stifter hier
in den rand reihen und drückt an den
rand gut ist
beteiligt ist auch die tomatensoße
die kann man übrigens auch ganz gut auf
vorrat machen
man fühlt sie dann nehme ich noch ganz
heiß im gläschen macht sie zu und
stellte auf den kopf und dann sind die
haltbar
verteidigen mozzarella käse und die
tomaten noch drüber und dann kann die
pizza auch gebacken werden
die pizza ist fertig und du darfst jetzt
direkt mal die mit den käse probieren
ich hab noch nie menschen gesehen der so
gefühlvoll pizza geschneit so lange
geredet und so lange gewartet um die
pizza steht die zahl schon seit etwa
fünf minuten
jetzt läuft er lag da nicht mehr raus
und schon stand es schmeckt ihm ja auf
jeden fall kriegt es noch bisschen
rucola drauf machen den nicht beim
backen schon drauf dann verbrennt als
orte bespielen stroh ist ganz gerne
etwas hast du mich gefragt ob ich das
mag
frag mich nur auf dieser linie 150 grad
vergiss nie zu heiß zu wissen wie
umbringt also mit lecker lecker heiß so
muss sein
die ist nicht zu stein augen zu labbrig
also richtig cool
ihr könnt ihr das hörte war ich mal
prompt ist er in rand wahnsinn oder
so muss die pizza sein als jetzt
ich möchte etwas die andere probieren
halte mich jetzt irgendwie an die zieht
hinter nachbarschaft muss mit dem ganzen
perfekt also eine zeit lang konnte er
dem rat keine pizza menschen dass er die
gb spinat also sperren jeder form
meine mama ist nur mit mir gemacht ich
fand es wirklich lecker und die probe
jetzt auch komisch die andere hat 180
grad und die auf jeden fall ist weiter
wir scheinen zu schmecken
falls ihr lust auf pizza habt dann geht
auf meinem blog senses blog.de
da stehen die wetten einfach die pizzas
normal war meine eiskalt und wie andere
strittig ist die heiße wie im video
trainings ist meine bücher direkt machen
packen aber die eine rundfahrt noch zu
halten auf jeden fall gibt es das rezept
auf meinem blog cellistin ist blog.de
ich würde mich freuen wenn ihr die pizza
nach macht und mir ein foto schickt auch
wenn gramm
da schaue ich mich immer ganz gerne an
wenig für alle berlin rand dem wegwerfen
ich nehme ganz kurz mit voller hohn
spricht entschuldigung für alle in den
weg werfen
ich finde es ich finde es echt ne
sauerei muss ich ehrlich sagen wenn
jemand seine pizza ist wenn nicht ist
das geht gar nicht
und hier ist die care ist käse drin also
den müsste nicht essen sowieso
ich geh jetzt aus der küche raus demo
hat kann gerne weiter machen und euch
viel spaß beim nach wacken
das wasser fehlt macht's gut dass ich es
jetzt